Москва оголосила про закриття до кінця жовтня поточного року трьох морських районів поблизу узбережжя анексованого Криму.
Це 12-мильна прибережна зона, яку Кремль після анексії українського півострова вважає своїми територіальними водами.
Такого роду заборони в міжнародній практиці судноплавства зазвичай обґрунтовуються військовими навчаннями
і спрямовані на забезпечення безпеки судноплавства в умовах, коли військові кораблі здійснюють запуски ракет.
Однак військові навчання зазвичай не тривають кілька місяців, констатують експерти.
Я бачу в цій забороні головним чином спробу Росії підкреслити свої претензії не тільки на Крим, але і на води навколо Криму.
Протягом останніх років Москва прагнула розширити свою зону впливу в Чорному морі
і використовувати військові навчання для того, щоб обмежити навігаційні та стратегічні можливості інших держав і перш за все України.
Російські прикордонні кораблі регулярно силовими методами затримують українських рибалок,
які опиняються в цих водах.
У 2018 році Росія навіть затримала малі катери ВМС України, які намагалися пройти з Чорного в Азовське море.
Умовно кажучи, цей закритий район, який вони оголосили, він складається з трьох частин.
Перша - навпроти мису Тарханкут.
Друга частина - на морській ділянці з Севастополя до Гурзуфа,
і третя ділянка частково розташована у територіальних водах України і частково - в територіальних водах Російської Федерації.
І ця третя  - найбільш проблемна ділянка.
Сенс нинішньої заборони стає зрозумілішим у контексті дипломатичного протистояння, яке триває вже не один рік.
Так, спеціальні станції в межах системи NAVTEX видають навігаційні попередження про виникнення небезпечних ситуацій для судноплавства.
До анексії Криму за це відповідала станція в Керчі, яка в 2014 році припинила роботу.
Потім за райони поблизу східного Криму стала відповідати станція в українському Бердянську,
а станція в Одесі - за райони на заході.
Однак останнім часом відповідальність за всі ці райони намагається перейняти російська станція в Новоросійську.
Координатором системи NAVTEX в регіоні Середземного, Чорного і Азовського морів є Гідрографічне бюро Військово-морських сил Іспанії.
Досі офіс в Кадісі ігнорував повідомлення станції в Новоросійську.
Однак 22 квітня іспанці вперше оприлюднили російське повідомлення по Криму.
Хоча цей район перебуває за лічені кілометри від материкової України і офіційно входить в зону відповідальності одеської станції NAVTEX.
У відповідь на запит DW в Іспанії пояснили, що керувалися міркуваннями безпеки.
У Києві позиція іспанського координатора NAVTEX викликала обурення, адже,
на думку експертів, сприяє легалізації протиправної російської окупації морських вод України.
Цю колізію неможливо вирішити в межах судноплавних організацій.
Вона повинна вирішуватися на найвищому рівні.
Міжнародні угоди і норми передбачають, що за безпеку судноплавства у власних водах відповідає Україна.
Але вона не може робити це у водах, які де-факто силою контролює Росія.
На Заході також уважно стежать за розвитком ситуації в Чорному морі.
Росія за допомогою збільшення збройного потенціалу поступово, підриваючи основи морського права та міжнародного права,
намагається здійснити повзучу анексію Чорного моря. І цими навчаннями Росія привчає до сірої правової зони.
Назву один приклад. В Криму відбувались навчання з цілком конкретним завданням - для проведення десантування у Південній Україні.
Сенс для Росії був у тому, щоб продемонструвати: ми можемо це реально зробити. Ми провели висадку.
В разі потреби головнокомандувач мусить лише у листі дати наказ –
провести цю операцію, тільки зі зміщенням на північний захід.
Тим часом Міжнародна морська організація, що діє під егідою ООН,
у відповідь на запит DW заявила, що міжнародні агентства не бажають бути втягнутими в політику
через питання морських карт і станцій NAVTEX навколо Криму.